[Musique]
je m'appelle zoé et j'ai 12 ans et 364
jours je vais avoir très envie je vais
vous raconter l'histoire d'une petite
fille cette histoire s'est passé il ya
maintenant environ deux ans dans un
petit village en afrique
c'est un petit village perdu dans le
bush un petit village sans route sans
eau sans électricité
c'est un petit village comme il y en a
tant d'autres en afrique
la petite fille est arrivée dans ce
village avec ses parents ils ont demandé
au chef du village
ferguson s'ils pouvaient pas celle ci
pouvait s'installer bien planté leur
tente quelque part le chef du village a
dit oui donc ils se sont installés
hélas tous les enfants du village sont
arrivés autour d'eux ils avaient le
sourire jusqu'aux oreilles et les yeux
qui pétillent et s'est passé quelque
chose de vraiment magique
d'indescriptible entre la petite fille
son frère et ses enfants pourtant il ne
se comprenaient pas
car la petite fille elle parlait
français et les enfants du village de
parler une langue locale le swahili et
ça ne les a pas empêchés de jouer de
danser ensemble jusqu'à très tard le
soir
il ya passé un moment vraiment
merveilleux et intense qu'elle
n'oubliera jamais elle n'avait jamais
vécu ça alors vous vous demandez peut
être comment cette petite fille et sa
famille sont arrivés dans ce village
comment deux enfants français se sont
retrouvés à jouer à danser avec des
enfants du bout du monde
alors revenons un peu en arrière
nous sommes mercredi 23 octobre 2013
pour beaucoup d'entre vous c'est un jour
comme les autres
mais ce jour là est un grand jour pour
une famille à la sortie de leur village
des choses se précisent se précipitent
il ya de l'effervescence voire de la
tension dans l'air c'est le grand jour
le jour du départ tant attendu
un départ pour un voyage qui durera
trois ans sur les chemins du monde
la petite fille donc allier un vélo
en afrique en inde et en asie pendant
son voyage elle appris beaucoup de
choses elle a appris par exemple tenait
elle a appris à partager
elle a appris à partager quelles que
soient nos cultures nos origines nos
différences elle a vu des gens qui leur
donnait tout alors que c'était des gens
qui n'avaient rien une fois il avait
accueilli dans une famille pour passer
la nuit
c'était la veille de noël et la famille
chez qu'il dormait leur a offert un gros
gâteau avec écrit dessus joyeux noël
pourtant cette famille était musulmane
les musulmans ne fêtent pas noël
une autre fois encore c'était la veille
de l'anniversaire de cette petite fille
vous avez la clé dans un petit temple en
thaïlande il avait discuté et sympathise
avec les villageois et le lendemain
matin c'est même village en sont revenus
avec un gâteau d'anniversaire
imaginez vous dans la rue vous
rencontrez une personne avec qui vous
sympathisez au cours de la conversation
cette personne vous fais savoir que
demain c'est son anniversaire
est-ce que cela vous viendra l'idée de
revenir demain vers cette même personne
pour lui souhaiter ne serait ce qu'un
bon anniversaire
ou alors vous êtes dans un parc entre un
pique-niqué des gens passent allez-vous
leur proposer de venir manger avec vous
et bien elle des moments comme ça elle
en a eu plein pendant son voyage elle a
aussi dû apprendre à sortir de sa zone
de confort elle a appris par exemple à
se laver de plein de manières
différentes
selon laver dans un fleuve ou une
rivière ou alors se douche avec une
bouteille d'un litre et demi d'eau
oui un litre et demi d'eau avec des
petits trous dans le bouffon pour
économiser l'eau ou alors elle a aussi
appris à pas se doucher du tout
et oui il faut aussi apprendre ce après
avoir passé des années à se doucher tous
les jours mais pendant son voyage elle a
surtout appris à se dépasser
elle m'a raconté une anecdote que je
tiens vraiment à partager avec vous
c'était sur une petite piste vraiment
pour y avait une petite qui tels des
gros cailloux du sable qui vous fait
tomber deux le moindre coup de [ __ ]
cette piste mené aux chutes cas lambeaux
les deuxièmes chutes les plus hautes
d'afrique
la petite vie était donc sur cette
petite piste avec sa famille est en
train de galérer ils en avaient
ras-le-bol
la petite fille a eu envie de jeter son
vélo de s'asseoir par terre et de dire
j'arrête mais n'était pas tout il y
avait son bureau séparant son petit
frère alors au fond d'elle même quelque
chose lui a dit non continue va jusqu'au
bout des passes toit et dans tous les
cas tu peux pas rester là c'est un trou
paumé ici donc là
alors la petite fille c'est dépassé elle
est allée au bout et elle a réussi et ça
il ne le regrette pas et ce fut une des
nombreuses occasions de se dépasser
car croyez moi il y en a eu il y en a eu
plein d'autres pendant ce voyage elle a
aussi dû apprendre des choses colère
mais elle m'a dit moi j'apprends le
français les maths comme mes amis mais
la différence c'est que moi je les
apprends à six sur la plage face à la
mer et que c'est quand même vachement
plus fun que d'être assis sur un banc
d'école à écouter un professeur c'est
vrai que sur nos vélos bas on pouvait
pas faire école tous les jours parce
qu'il [ __ ] et des fournils fatigué
mais quand s'imiter on s'y mettait
vraiment parce qu'on avait envie d'être
au même niveau que nos copains français
elle a terminé en disant j'ai beaucoup
de chance tout ce qu'elle a pris pendant
ce voyage elle ne l'aurait jamais appris
dans les livres d'école car c'est vrai
j'ai jamais vu de manuels de cours sur
le dépassement de soi ou sur le partage
serait drôle ouais ça lui albert alors
comment s'est passé ton cours sur
dépassement de soi oh c'était pas
évident on a dû manger un truc
méconnaissable dans un endroit pas
franchement très clean je me croyais
dans koh lanta moi qui croyais que tout
devait être désinfecté aux normes haccp
et le courage parlons-en du courage et
d'aller entre 50 et 90 km par jour sur
trois continents ça ça lui a donné un
courage une persévérance qu'elle ne
pensait même pas avoir finalement tout
ce qu'elle a appris le partage le
dépassement de soi le courage la
tolérance tout ça elle a pris grâce à
l'école de la vie eh bien vous l'auriez
compris
et bien sûr vous l'avez compris cette
petite fille c'est moi
[Applaudissements]